Ça vous dirait une vidéo sur être ch'ti ?
RT si oui, biloute.
Ce qui est bien c'est que nous les ch'tis en france,
on a vraiment une image très classe.
J'sais pas si vous le savez, mais moi
je suis 100% ch'ti.
Je suis né dans le Pas-de-Calais,
j'ai grandi dans les corons,
tous mes grands parents étaient mineurs de fond dans les mines de charbon.
Bref, la totale.
Comme beaucoup de gens du nord,
enfin quand je dis "du nord",
je veux dire globalement,
des "Hauts-de-France".
J'adore la cassonade et d'ailleurs je déteste qu'on dise
"Ouais, c'est du sucre roux quoi !"
Pour moi ça, c'est une "wassingue",
j'adore les crêpes à la bière,
et je sais prononcer "potjevleesch".
Enfin j'crois...
Pour moi pleuvoir c'est "dracher".
Je trouve qu'un terril c'est vraiment magnifique.
Et la couleur de ma peau est la même que...
que celle d'une endive.
Malheureusement, nous les ch'tis on est victimes de certains clichés.
Disons que pour beaucoup de gens en France,
un ch'ti c'est:
Un beauf consanguin, avec une coupe mulet,
qui s'appelle Dylan.
fan de tuning, chômeur raciste,
supporter du RCL avec des tatouages de Johnny,
qui se nourrit uniquement dans les baraque à frites,
et qui est déjà passé à 3 reprises
dans l'émission Confessions Intimes.
Tout ça est strictement...
"FAUX min tiot !"
Moi par exemple, je suis ch'ti et je correspond
à aucun de ces critères.
À part peut-être que j'ai un prénom américain,
mais ça c'est...
Bon OK ! J'ai pas d'arguments.
Mon père aussi il a un prénom typiquement ch'ti...
il s'appelle Jacky.
Bon moi ça me fait moyennement rire parce que déjà c'est mon père,
et c'est également...
mon deuxième prénom.
En même temps les médias, ils aident pas à améliorer l'image des ch'tis
ils pourraient nous mettre un petit peu en valeur,
mais les seuls ch'tis qu'on nous montre à la télé c'est...
"Un pot de cornichons ! Un pot de cornichons !"
"Ton soutif' dans mon lit c'est une blague ?"
"On est chaud boulette !"
D'accord, donc ce sont ces gens là qui nous représentent.
Nickel !
Pourtant on n'est vraiment pas tous comme ça,
on dirait que pour ces émissions ils ont pris une poignée de ch'tis,
les plus beaufs possible.
J'suis sûr qu'au casting de l'émission le mec il devait être comme ça:
"Alors prochain candidat pour l'émission 'Les ch'tis en Thaïlande',
donc Jordan,
22 ans.
Bah, vas-y présente toi un petit peu en quelques mots,
qui es-tu ?
*fort accent ch'ti*
MOI ?!
OK c'est bon t'es pris !
Pas besoin de faire les essais,
j'te mets directement en vainqueur de l'émission."
*Étrange cri avec sa langue*
Alors pour ceux qui en douteraient je précise,
c'est pas parce que t'es ch'ti que t'es un beauf.
C'est juste que comme le chtimi,
le patois du nord,
est souvent associé aux classes populaires,
on a du mal à imaginer un bobo qui parlerait chtimi,
mais pourtant c'est possible.
Ce serait chelou mais possible...
[J'irais bien voir une petite exposition sur Pollock...]
J'iro bin vir eune tchiote expo sur Pollaock..
[Ou je mangerais bien un petit brunch,
Ou j'mingero bin un tchiot brunch,
dans une baraque à frite vegan]
dins eune baraque al frite vegan.
[Euh, Cassiopée qu'en penses-tu ?]
Euh, Cassiopée quoi qu't'en pinses ?
[Cassiopée, arrêtes de pleurer, tu pleures tout le temps.]
Cassiopée, arrêt' eud braire, té brais toudis.
[Que souhaites-tu faire ?]
Quoi qu'té veux faire ?
[Tu veux acheter quelque chose chez Christian Dior ?]
Té veux acater quette cosse chez Christian Dior ?
[Écoute si tu n'es pas contente,
Écoute chi té nin contint,
tu n'as qu'à venir me voir ici,
t'as qu'à v'nir eum vir ichi,
je t'apprendrais le yoga.]
j'va t'apprindre eul yoga, hein.
[Allo ? Attends mais je te reconnais toi,
Allo ? Attinds mais j'te r'conno ti
tu viens du même coin que moi.]
té d'min coin.
[Oui, tu es du XVIème, mon gars.]
Ouais, t'es du 16ème, biloute.
Alors oui, comme beaucoup de gens de chnord,
je parle couramment chtimi.
Enfin le chtimi du Pas-de-Calais,
mais bon j'ai aucun mérite.
J'ai simplement retenu des phrases qu'on me disait quand j'étais petit:
Attends mais... J'étais trop maltraité en fait !
Le chtimi c'est très cool,
mais faut avouer que c'est pas
non plus le langage le plus sexy du monde.
Disons que je vois mal une pub méga classe genre:
Mais version chtimi...
"Nechprecho quo qu'té veux d'pluch ?"
["Toujours avec une petite cuillère de sucre roux"]
"Toudis avec eun tchiote cuillère
eud cassonat de chnord"
Mais comme j'adore le chtimi,
et que je pense que c'est un patois trop méconnu,
je vais vous donner une mini leçon de chtimi.
Si je vous dis:
Ça veut dire:
"Moi" devient "mi" et "ça" devient "châ"
D'ailleurs pour bien prononcer "châ", c'est un subtil mélange entre "cha" et "cho".
Ça donne "châ", mais attention petit piège:
Le chat, l'animal, ne se prononce pas "châ" mais "kâ".
Là encore, un subtil mélange entre "ka" et "ko" ce qui donne "kâ".
Du coup, une phrase correcte serait par exemple:
"Mi j'parle comme châ et châ...
ch'est min kâ !"
À part à "Bienvenue chez les Ch'tis",
on dirait que les gens connaissent rien du nord,
c'est dommage, on dirait que pour eux,
les Hauts-de-France c'est juste un désert
où il y a rien à faire, rien à visiter.
[Oui, mon petit ? Attends tais-toi, je te rappelle mec.]
Ouais min tiot ? Attinds ferme eut guiffe j'te rappelle biloute.
[Que puis-je pour vous ?]
Quo qu'te veux ?
Cliente:
Bonjour, qu'est-ce que je pourrais visiter à Lens ?
Norman:
À Lens ?
Euh, alors là euh... bonne question.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a à visiter à Lens ?
Euh, bah y'a un truc un peu plus loin à visiter à Lens, c'est...
c'est... Lille.
La ville de Lille, après euh... je sais pas.
Eh ben ça c'est encore une idée reçue,
parce que figurez vous qu'à Lens par exemple,
il y a l'annexe du Louvre, ouais le vrai Louvre de Paris.
Bon me demandez pas ce que ça fout là, mais c'est là...
Maintenant le nord de la france c'est devenu cool,
il y a même un film de Christopher Nolan qui s'appelle Dunkerque,
c'est classe quand même.
Mais j'avoue que j'aurais jamais imaginé qu'un jour,
un gros film américain porterait le nom d'une petite ville du chnord.
"Après 'The Dark Knight'...
'Interstellar'...
et 'Inception'...
'Roubaix', un film de Christopher Nolan.
Et bientôt la saga continue avec 'Tourcoing'
'Marcq-en-Baroeul'
et 'Montigny-en-Gohelle' "
Vous l'aurez compris, les ch'tis c'est pas forcément que des fans de tuning ou des Tuches.
Vous en connaissez peut-être même certains.
Évidemment Dany Boon, mais aussi Marguerite Yourcenar,
Matisse, Alain Decaux ou le légèrement célèbre Charles de Gaulle.
Le Nord de la France, c'est le musée naturel de l'épopée minière,
qui a inspiré Emile Zola, dans l'un des livres les plus célèbres au monde.
C'est un geyser culturel !
Avec "Lille 3000", le "Mainsquare Festival d'Arras",
le "Carnaval de Dunkerque" ou encore la "Braderie de Lille".
Ou encore le "Marché de Noël de Strasbourg" !
Mais bon, ça c'est à Strasbourg.
Donc si vous êtes des Hauts-de-France vous devez partager cette vidéo,
afin de lutter pour notre cause,
et prouver au reste du monde que nous les ch'tis,
on n'est pas juste ça:
On a un peuple plein de ressources.
Connu pour notre chaleur humaine,
et surtout bien loin des clichés qu'on nous colle à la peau
Donc non, désolé on n'est pas consanguins.
Moi les seuls consanguins que je connaisse, c'est les Lannister,
or nous, on vient du Nord.
Ciao biloute !
Quand vous cliquez ici là sur ce bouton, depuis un téléphone ou un ordi, bah ça fait un truc nouveau.
Allez-y essayez, cliquez avec votre doigt ou votre souris.
Voilà... pas mal, non ?
Plutôt cool, hyper simple pour s'abonner, beaucoup plus instinctif,
donc merci Monsieur YouTube et puis merci à vous je vous aime énormément.
*Chuchotant*
Lâchez un petit pouce en l'air svp, au revoir.